innocent civilians suffering as russia's
unprovoked invasion of ukraine enters a
new phase after failing to quickly
capture key cities like kiev putin
appears to be shifting his focus to
inflict as much damage to the country as
possible the city of mariopol refusing
russia's demand to surrender even after
enduring weeks of devastating airstrikes
ukrainian president zielinski continues
his call for peace but says his country
won't give any land to russia
i think that we have to use any format
any chance in order to have a
possibility of negotiating the
possibility of talking to putin
if these attempts fail
that would mean
that this is a third world war
this comes as president biden prepares
to head to europe where he'll attend a
major nato summit in brussels as well as
a meeting with the polish president in
warsaw jeff
jeff paul is in la vie ukraine with the
latest
jeff yeah air raid sirens continue to go
off here in the western ukrainian city
of levive and despite those warnings
people here in the city are very much
trying to get on with their daily lives
as much as possible but they do realize
that at any moment things could change
and they are watching very closely
what's happening just outside of this
city center especially to the east and
to the south in coastal towns like
mariopol where hundreds of thousands of
people right now are trapped and trying
to get out of harm's way after russia
issued
that ultimatum for the city to lay down
its arms the mayor didn't even wait for
the deadline and rejected that offer to
surrender without hesitation officials
say after weeks of heavy shelling and
constant bombardments they estimate
upwards of 2300 people have died in the
city residents of this area who've
survived the constant attack say battles
are taking place on nearly every street
there is no miracle anymore they bombed
everything it's uh all this uh drama
theater uh and the maternity hospital
and the art school it's all of this is
very catchy for the news for the media
but uh
in reality they bombed everything we
don't have maruka anymore we have to
build this
build this city from scratch
in kiev crews are sifting through what's
left of a shopping center after it was
blown up last night ukraine estimates as
many as eight were killed after a
russian fired rocket blasted through the
mall in that city the explosion
charred cars and sent shrapnel into
nearby homes and businesses now russia
claims that they only targeted the
shopping center because it was housing
ukrainian missiles and rockets but
that claim has not been independently
confirmed by anyone in fact one mother
who spoke just today about that incident
that her daughter was working in that
very shopping center and you can just
imagine some of those thoughts just
thinking if that attack could happen
just the day before
judge janine all right jeff thanks so
much stay safe
dana i'm going to start with you we're
in the fourth week of this and every day
we hear about more and more attacks on
civilians civilian protesters civilian
protesters being shot and killed and we
hear more and more about literally war
crimes happening when zielinski talks
about the beginning of the third world
war
is he really is he really talking about
where we are possibly well actually you
know that phrase has been used since the
first day of this invasion by some
because um one of the things that
president biden is trying to do and then
other nato countries is to figure out
how do you provide the ukrainians enough
so that they can defend themselves
without
again i disagree with how we are
describing how putin is provoked because
he's apparently provoked by everything
but that to provoke him into a nuclear
war nobody wants that i don't think
putin wants that i don't i don't really
know what putin wants but i imagine that
he doesn't want that so um i think that
this trip that biden is going to take
this week is important i think it's good
that he's going i think that it's time
for some more front seat diplomacy uh he
sent kamla harris that did not
necessarily move the needle so now he
has to go and i think it's better to be
sitting in a room face to face with the
other nato leaders rather than on zoom
because it's not that's not going to cut
it they have so many important decisions
to make and they have terrible a
terrible dilemma
in this situation and joey could answer
this question i have that's been going
through my mind which is we're giving
the ukrainians enough to keep
they are doing pretty well defending
themselves and it could be that zolensky
thinks that he can keep the capital city
of kiev
but
outside of kiev if you don't give them
enough to win quickly or to beat them
back quickly then you're just going to
lose slowly
and
if that happens then you're going to see
the death toll of civilians increase
much more you know joey i'll go to you
on that you know it appears that we're
at a stalemate right now that there were
there was a deadline that was given to
zielinski at 10 pm our time last night
to surrender uh and he hasn't gotten
married a pole uh
putin he hasn't gotten keiv and he's
trying to destroy and crush the spirits
of the ukrainians but when you're at a
stalemate it's a very dangerous time is
it not and what does putin do now
well i think when zielinski says then
it'll be world war three i think what
zielinski's saying in my opinion i can't
translate word for word is
if we continue to hold him off he's
going to eventually he being putin is
going to eventually use chemical weapons
use nuclear weapons and then the west
has already said essentially when that
happens they're involved and so i think
that's i think what zolinski's saying is
hey you all under what he's saying is
you all underestimated us we're able to
stay in this fight because of your help
actually because the weapons you are
giving us if we stay in this fight and
don't win decisively that's what's next
and he may be true that might be true i
think um
we try to report on this every single
day and you can't report on this one day
to the other we say they still haven't
gotten mariupol well they haven't gotten
mario pole but mario poll is a wasteland
of war right so
does it matter if they're sitting in the
city center or not and that's part of
the problem here just like what dana was
saying just to kind of wrap this up if
the end result is were three months of
war
and 30 000 people dead and russia is
standing in the center of kiev when you
look back what do you say you know what
was the purpose of this war what was
gained from it what was gained from
those 30 000 deaths it may be the next
30 years of insurgency but that's just
more innocent people dying any
insurgency turns into ieds in moscow
before it turns into ukraine being
independent again and you know greg with
respect to that i mean let's assume that
he just you know it scorched earth from
this point on he will never defeat the
ukrainian spirit and the russians they
don't appear to have the ability to
ability to actually occupy what do the
russians do at that point i uh you know
your your fantasy is that they take care
of the problem themselves but i don't
know if that's going to happen because
putin is so far removed it's weird he's
he's essentially destroying the very
thing that he claims that he cherishes
which is ukraine i mean it's like a
really bitter acrimonious breakup where
the the the creep goes well if i can't
have you no one will and then it gets
real bad and then it gets real bad and
it really is the opposite of damage
control what he's doing and i i'm very
pessimistic about about biden just
because he doesn't seem like he's in any
particular rush to fix this and uh and
we know that i mean joey was we were
talking about how many examples there
are places where we've helped
and it it didn't help and i'm beginning
to feel that like the longer we do this
the longer it goes on and the longer
that it goes on the more people die it's
really weird this is the longest fog of
war
i've seen and the only thing that's
really clear is the brutality i mean
both sides say they're winning you know
how can that be both sides are calling
each other nazis and russia was first
when they did that i don't know how to
break that stalemate but we need some
kind of creative thinking uh uh and and
you know i go back to the only example
that i can think of is that like you
know
when uh when trump went to north korea
it was like let's just see what happens
let's shake the box see what happens you
know we can promise something if it
doesn't work out it doesn't work out at
least it was innovative and it it
introduced another variable into a into
a situation where we already knew the
variables there were not working and so
now we're like four weeks in and we're
no we're kind of in the same place we
were before well we're four weeks in on
this but we're we're since 2014 on this
war and that's the part we always forget
the reason why putin was able to sell
this to begin with is what's happening
in donbass and and i'm not taking a
position on that because quite frankly
i'd have to read a bunch of books to
even get there
but i think it's important when
americans sit here and say you know what
it was real easy for charlie wilson's
war that didn't really bother us until
we're in a war for 20 years right like i
get really aggravated that i've sat in
front of a television camera now for
almost 10 years since losing my leg
saying americans please ask questions
before we get into another war please
ask for accountability and if you do
that now i mean you're in putin's pocket
right exactly i mean come on there has
to be an opportunity for americans to
understand what are what we're getting
into and at any point no matter how
righteous the cause jessica and the
whole idea now if we're fighting to this
point where we're at a stalemate it's
all about diplomacy isn't it a lot of it
is at this point and i thought it was
really important that john kirby in his
briefing this afternoon basically said
we're doing things that we're not
telling you about which is kind of what
everyone's been asking for and you
expect that your government and the most
powerful government in the world with
the most weapons and all that is doing
more than they're publicly coming out
and telling us about and and that is a
game changer because one consistent
thing that i've noticed from everyone
i've talked about this with and everyone
is on the same side here whether you're
republican and democrat is
we want to know what are you doing for
them these people are making such
personal appeals zelinski
has just
the videos he's putting out theatrical
emotional he's taking us on a tour of
ukraine that makes it palpable for the
average person sitting in their home in
kentucky and we're what are we doing and
john kirby he told us we're doing things
those missile systems that are in there
we're not saying we gave it to them
we're not going to tell you what's on
the ground there but i'm telling you
that we're doing more than you think
that we're doing but i had one thing
judging before we go in terms of that
creative thinking it's something that it
doesn't have to do with weapons but it
could be something that really could
help the actual russian people and not
help putin so could you figure out a way
to have a creative banking system that
allows the people who are in russia to
actually that one that either can't
leave russia or the ones that who have
left russia already like that set up
shop in kyrgyzstan as a tech company can
you find a way for them to be able to be
a part of the international banking
system or our banking system but
separate out the leaders like putin and
the oligarchs and the military so that
you create some sort of a fissure that
way which is a creative way to do it
without weapons that is too smart yes
it's never going to happen it's too
intelligent
but not only that i mean you draw a
distinction and that is between putin
and the russian people and we've got to
recognize that the russian people a lot
of them are being oppressed by him as
well hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else